gérard longuet sénateur l'est
républicain et ancien ministre de la
défense le jour on apprend que l'armée
française a tiré ses premiers missiles
de croisière sur l'irak est l'invité de
preuves par 3 bonsoir et merci d'être
avec nous pour réagir d'abord bien sûr l
actualité de la presse régionale avec
sur rendez-vous de public sénat avec la
fp et dailymotion trois grandes
questions comme chaque semaine gérard
longuet ce que vous avez bien compris la
leçon du scrutin c'est ce qu'affirme le
coeur sur la main
tous les responsables politiques et
dimanche depuis dimanche heure on
s'aperçoit que ça n'est peut-être pas si
évident
deuxième question que vous posera
deborah claude de l' agence
france-presse à droite toute
est ce que c'est la réponse que doit
apporter votre party les républicains ou
la guerre des chefs et relancer on le
voit encore aujourd'hui enfin troisième
question faut-il une recomposition
politique c'est une petite musique qu'on
entend là encore depuis dimanche chez
manuel valls ou encore chez votre avis
jean pierre raffarin
vous répondrez sur ce point tout à
l'heure à mickaël szames s d'abord cet
autre mot que l'on entend depuis le chef
des régionales la prochaine fois ce sera
en tentant la catastrophe politique
comprendre donc la victoire du front
national question gérard longuet est-ce
que vous avez vous le sentiment d'avoir
bien compris la leçon des régionales
non non non non il y a en apparence dans
l'opinion française trois grands groupes
d'opinion la gauche avec un leader
institutionnelle le président de la
république
l'extrême-droite mais dont les le corps
électoral vient de toutes les opinions
française avec le front national et son
leader marine le pen
et puis un paquet centrale qui est
dominée par les républicains mais avec
les centristes qui tient mais qui se
posent des questions et tu pourras je
n'ai pas tout compris parce que
premièrement notre groupe je vois à peu
près ce qu'il ait des républicains des
gens modérés qui acceptent la
construction européenne qui accepte
l'ouverture des frontières et qui au
fond souhaite que le pays soit plus
compétitif plus qu'ils réussissent plus
sur le plan économique donc plus
libérale qui n'a pas de véritable état
d'âme on arrive à le comprendre mais il
n'est pas majoritaire ce groupe c
30 35% peut aller à 40 ce qui était le
cas de philippe richert dans la région à
laquelle j'appartiens le grand est le
front national et a atteint des niveaux
et en particulier dans le grand test
dans le monde rural des niveaux
spectaculaires 40% parfois 50%
c'est un vote qui s'est stabilisé entre
le premier et le deuxième tour ont
peuplé est un vote de protestation c'est
un vote d'adhésion mais adhésion à quoi
de parler de vote protestataire serait
une illusion
ce sont des gens qui adhèrent à quoi on
sait pas très bien
il faut écouter madame le pen parle d'un
état protecteur donc elle imagine une
protection généralisée et chacun y
trouve son compte dans cette protection
les uns contre les étrangers avec la
fermeture des frontières
les autres avec la fermeture des
importations pour préserver l'emploi la
lutte contre l'assistanat l'assistanat
c'est les autres par définition sur
l'argent qu'on revoie c'est normal
l'argent que les autres soit c'est de
l'assistanat et bien ce resort est très
puissant dans un pays où les
prélèvements sont considérables donc
vous avez un bloc qui est quand même
constitué maintenant je parle de la
gauche la gauche est dans une situation
de crise en réalité et je voudrais en
prendre comme témoignage les résultats
électoraux de jean pierre masseret jean
pierre masseret au premier tour
candidat de la gauche officielle fait 16
% et au deuxième tour désavoué par son
parti désavoué par gouvernement désavoué
par manuel valls fait cependant 14%
ça veut dire quoi c'est là que ce ne
sont pas les mêmes électeurs vous avez
des électeurs socialistes du premier
tour qui ont voté richerdt sinon
richerdt n'aurait pas fait son score
étonnant est spectaculaire et vous avez
des électeurs d'extrême gauche mélenchon
laurent voir écolo dans certains cas qui
ont choisi masseret pour dire nous la
droite gouvernementale où le front
national
bonnet blanc blanc bonnet et donc nous
avons une gauche gouvernementale en
apparence à 30% en réalité
vous n'avez plus de deux tiers qui
suivent hollande et un tiers qui ne
suivent pas hollande mais qui ne veulent
pas de la droite
alors donc on a une situation qui au
fond les terminaux cerise sur le gâteau
créer un chef pour la droite
un chef pour la droite extrême pour
l'extrême droite pour le lait s'ouvre
infa les populistes comme on pourrait
aller s'appelait madame le pen achète
institutionnels
hollande a fait le vide autour de lui et
pour la droite je confie pour la droite
s'en empare du coup plus comprend va en
parler dans un beaucoup plus compliqué
tous les cas il sait cela se traduit par
un certain désarroi alors ordonné à
xavier bertrand n'a pas de mots assez
durs lui pour qualifier la classe
politique déconnectée dit il des
souffrances des français en les côtés
puis vous réagissez j'ai pris cette
campagne un peu comme un coup de poing
en pleine figure
et c'est vrai que ça a changé à jamais
ma façon de faire de la politique et je
dois dire que ça oblige à se remettre en
question et à partir du moment où ou
depuis ces trente dernières années la
classe politique a failli il y à bien
une faillite collective et où j'ai fait
partie de cette classe politique
aujourd'hui je demande à être jugé sur
ce que je vais faire à la tête de la
région en m'occupant des gens et en me
consacrant à 100% ce alors gérard
longuet est ce que vous vous
reconnaissez avoir pris part à cette
faillite collective
non pas du tout et je trouve que xavier
bertrand sort d'une campagne brillante
il a il a réussi un très beau combat
sans doute est il revenu le temps de la
campagne a la base je rappelle qu'il
était ministre du travail
et c'est un poste particulièrement
exposé on est bien placé pour juger la
difficulté des gens qui ne trouvent pas
d'emploi et qui dans les conditions
économiques de la france ne risque pas
d'en trouver demain matin ils arrivent à
tort disons qu'il y là il exprime une
émotion
l'émotion d'un candidat qui vient de
loin qui a réussi qui a bien réussi qui
a réussi personnellement vous donne des
droits le droit de dire aux autres
réveillez vous la vraie question est la
suivante pourquoi la france ne fabrique
pas d'emploi parce qu'on n'est pas
compétitif pourquoi les capitaux ne
viennent qu'en france parce que nous ne
sommes pas attractif pourquoi on
entreprend prix en france parce que nous
sommes trop réglementée et ça ce sont
des faits objectifs que se traduit sur
le terrain par en effet
beaucoup de désarroi chez nos copains
alors on va revenir sur y ait des
explications rationnelles ou est
annoncée même en matière d'emploi
notamment sur l'apprentissage et la
formation professionnelle des chômeurs
on en parlera un peu plus tard mais en
le jouant dans la presse et une envie
qui s'exprime de plus en plus dans tous
les journaux 1,2 du monde au parisien en
passant par le figaro d'un coup de balai
dans la dans la classe politique
est ce qu'une génération doit s'effacer
en tous les cas je les fais dans mon nom
ma propre région j'ai considéré qu'à mon
âge je pouvais ne pas être candidat et
dans le département de la meuse nous
avons fait une liste de jeunes qui s'en
est plutôt bien sorti un leader qui
venait de la vie professionnelle et des
jeunes élus mais qui avaient tous 30 et
35 ans bon moi je considère que moi je
suis très heureux d'être sénateur vous
m'invitez je viens mais je ne suis pas
en train de ramer pour m'imposer partout
et tout le temps ça doit vous rappeler
des souvenirs ses discours aujourd'hui
vous avez fait partie cela après l'échec
après l'échec de 1981
nous avons pris en main le parti
républicain avec françois léotard avec
quelques autres avec alain madelin avec
charles millon et nous avions tous entre
30 et 35 ans et l'âge de le faire et
donc très près normal que les jeunes
remplacent les plus âgées
alors là pas dire que les plus agiles
soit inutile ces appels à renouvellement
à la jeunesse auront un certain écho
parce qu'on s'aperçoit que le front
national
il séduit la jeunesse vous avez vu là
également il est regardé de près avec
une raison forte et qu' évidemment seul
le front national peut mettre en avant
c'est qu'il n'a jamais exercé aucune
responsabilité et c'est un atout
considérable vis-à-vis de la jeunesse de
pouvoir dire les autres sont des vieux
cons et nous on fera beaucoup mieux
sauf qu'ils n'ont jamais rien fait
est-ce que selon vous le front national
dont la vigueur qui a encore progressé
entre les deux tours va finir par percer
son plafond de verre commander ce qui
peut dépasser les 50%
très clairement il en apporte la
démonstration et dans l'est de la france
si vous prenez une ligne
je dirais boulogne calais qu'elle est
perpignan et tout ce qui est à l'est
vous avez souvent un front national
majoritaire dans les villes dans l'est
dans des communes dans des cantons et il
s'en est fallu de peu pour qu'il le soit
sur des espaces plus grands à l'ouest et
c'est intéressant pour des raisons de
sociologie politique il n'est pas
présent dans le sud-ouest parce que la
gauche fait son travail dans le
nord-ouest parce que les catholiques
l'héritage catholique même si les gens
ne sont plus très croyant en tous les
cas pas assez fait également son travail
de fond d'air mais même là où le front
national était inexistant il ya six ans
vous le voyez à 12 15 % il ya un seul
endroit le front national est absent
dans les grandes villes à paris et s'il
vous prend déjà par curiosité je me suis
amusé à regarder le 16e l'endroit le
plus chic le le front national ces
quatre passants est ce que vous diriez
également que la gauche a bien fait son
travail avec le front républicain pour
faire élire vous conviendra dans le nord
la gauche la gauche je vous rappelle
elle était dans une situation et ne
pouvait plus l'emporter et la gauche
algérien de réveillon elle ne le
reverront candidats ne pouvaient plus
l'emporter et elle pouvait elle non
la gauche gouvernementale a sans doute
joué le jeu je crois que l'extrême
gauche est restée chez elle
j'aimerais avoir votre avis maintenant
sur leurs comptes du crédit la gauche de
dentelles sous les électeurs dont la
gontrie alors j'aimerais avoir votre
avis sur la reconduction par acclamation
aujourd'hui de claude bartolone comme
président de l'assemblée nationale par
acclamation par son groupe socialiste
c'était l'occasion d'une passe d'armes
droite gauche tout à l'heure sur fond de
déclarations vous souvenez sur la race
blanche
écoutez cet échange donc lors des
questions d'actualité un homme éminent
de la république qui aujourd'hui via de
déserter son bureau a osé proférer des
insultes graves
qui sont d'ailleurs du domaine pénal
temps de l'injure publique que de la
diffamation à l'égard d'une candidate
monsieur le premier ministre nous avons
cette deuxième insultes de voir que le
président de l'assemblée nationale n'a
pas eu le courage devant l'hémicycle de
venir s'expliquer vous nous inviter à
sortir de la campagne électorale sortez
vous même de cette campagne électorale
ces polémiques elles sont derrière nous
monsieur goasguen les cellules derrière
nous et soyons encore une fois à la
hauteur de ce qu'attendent les français
et moi je veux ici répété une nouvelle
fois mon soutien et ma confiance en feu
de barcelone est ce que vous êtes
d'accord avec le premier ministre parce
que sinon allez mika derrière nous non
je pense que claude bartolone a exagéré
c'est un homme d'expérience ce n'est pas
le premier venu s'il n'est pas non plus
un jeune premier il a de longues années
d'expérience politique derrière lui il
ne fallait pas fût-ce en fin de campagne
attaquer ça sent bon le valérie pécresse
en le traitant de raciste d'autant plus
que c'était pas complètement
désintéressé bartolone jouer le vote
communautaire ce qui n'est pas non plus
très élégant on sait qu'il ya un vote
communautaire dans dans certains
arrondissements de l'île de france
bartolone a sans doute fait appel à ce
vin il a d'ailleurs il n'a pas été
entendu puisque le vote a été équilibrée
dans tous les jeux rappelle qu'il avait
donc accuse effectivement son adversaire
des règlements l'a emporté de
redescendre de allons défendre et de
défendre versailles neuilly et la race
blanche
voilà il a reconnu aujourd'hui devant
ses troupes que la formule n'était pas
forcément calibrer la création il a eu
raison de faire amende honorable c'est
une douce et une amende modeste mais
c'est quand même un début de commandes
de reconnaissance de la hague a affirmé
que sa formule sa formule était
pénalement répréhensible vous estimez
que je devrais y avoir des poursuites
aujourd'hui je crois que c'est pas
inutile de
de solliciter la justice pourquoi parce
que la france depuis 1970 et d'une façon
croissante est une france diverse et en
ile de france est une vérité il suffit
de prendre le métro pour ça en aux
comptes
il faut surtout pas envenimer se traiter
mutuellement de raciste je pense que il
faut manier ces mots avec plus de
prudence surtout quand on exerce des
responsabilités
donc on appeler à la justice c'est
intéressant de savoir ce que les
justices en pense est-ce que selon vous
claude bartolone est devenu indigne de
la fonction qu'il occupe il n'était pas
au perchoir aujourd'hui on l'a vu c'est
ce que dit laurent wauquiez
je laisse alors ok sa formule
bon encore une question est ce qu'il
faut on a parlé de la gauche et du front
républicain ni un instant ce qu'il faut
comment associer la gauche à la gestion
des régions où la victoire était
possible pour vous amis donc grâce à
cette mobilisation des électeurs de
gauche même si vous faites deux choses
le front républicain n'est pas
d'actualité
ce qui nous sépare du front national ce
sont les options du front national mais
le front national n'a pas l'intention de
prendre le pouvoir par la violence
ce qui était le cas du front républicain
dans les années 30
et c'était une pouvait l'imaginer contre
les ligues ou en espagne c'est ce à quoi
fait référence la gauche elle se trompe
de période se trompent de combat
je combats le front national parce que
aucune de ces solutions les pertinentes
pour notre pays un rempart alors avec la
gauche s'est divisée et la comparaison
pas de calais grand s est très
intéressante à cet égard lorsque le
grand nord ce que dans le grand est une
liste de gauche maintient elle fait des
voix parce que vous avez des électeurs
de gauche qui nous veulent ni l'un ni
l'autre
lorsque la gauche ne se présente pas je
crois profondément qu elle se divise
qu'une fraction de cette gauche ne
souhaitent pas du tout du front national
et une autre fraction s'en fiche
si elle s'en fiche c'est qu'ils ne
croient pas au danger
le subversion du front national on a
parlé du plafond de verre que tout à
l'heure vous avez fait le distinguo
selon les régions françaises mais est ce
que pour vous la qualification de marine
le pen pour le second tour de la
présidentielle est acquise est ce qu
elle a des chances sérieuses de
l'emporter alors qu'est-ce que je
qualification soit probable c'est très
fort qu'elle puisse l'emporter je ne
crois absolument pas je ne crois
absolument pas parce qu'il y à un fonds
commun qui nous fédère qui ait la
démocratie la construction européenne
l'acceptation de l'ouverture des
frontières nous ne voulons pas d'une
france repliée sur elle même et c'est un
bon petit une commune enfin c'est une
attitude c'est une attitude commune de
la droite et au moins des deux tiers de
la gauche au moins des deux tiers de la
gauche donc ça fait plus de 50 % même si
la forme est de 50% mais en revanche à
pose un vrai problème c'est que le
président élu contre madame le pen si
c'est le cas on aura pas de majorité
absolue non plus et qu'il devra en tenir
compte
alors on en reparlera dans un instant on
va maintenant évoquer la situation chez
les républiques à votre parti et gérard
longuet les secousses donc se
multiplient alors quelle ligne quel
projet faut-il opter pour à droite toute
et puis il ya également le
chamboule-tout dans l'organigramme avec
l'érection sans délai on a on a eu la
confirmation tout à l'heure de la vice
présidente nathalie kosciusko morizet on
écoute d'abord cette dernière
hier et on accueille deborah claude de
l' agence france-presse
je vais pas vendre mes convictions pour
une place je trouve d'ailleurs curieux
au moment où on annonce un débat sur la
ligne de pensée évincé ceux qui ne sont
pas d'accord
croire que le parti se renforce en
s'épurant s'éveille dessalinienne moi je
pense que le parti se renforce en
débattant et c'est justement de débat
qu'on a besoin au lendemain du jour au
front national a fait son plus haut
score de l'histoire
deborah cox bonsoir mon fort gay et mme
kehm parle d'un parti avec des vieilles
idées stalinienne est ce que c'est votre
avis est ce qu'il ya des idées
staliniennes dans votre parti est ce que
c'est encore un parti je crois que c'est
excessif c'est liens n'ont qu'un
président exerce l'autorité que les
statuts lui donne c'est son droit
il se trouve qu'il a choisi librement de
nommer madame kosciusko morizet
vice-présidente et moi j'en étais
content parce que c'est une personnalité
je partage pas nécessairement ses idées
mais une personnalité innovantes forte
il décide de lui retirer sa
vice-présidence c'est statutairement son
droit
j'aurais préféré qu'elle reste j'aurais
préféré qu'on vote et qu'on parle en
effet mais on n'a pas voté par les
avants de la nommer on ne vote pas et on
ne parle pas au moment où elle n'est
plus en place non c'est un peu un
problème institutionnel permet à votre
sentiment
je pense que le fonds doit l'emporter
sur la forme sur la forme c'est vrai que
nathalie un petit souci c'est qu'elle
elle parle parce qu elle est
vice-présidente et un vice présidence
est comme son nom l'indiqué quelqu'un
qui seconde le président or
manifestement
elle n'est pas sur la ligne du président
qu'il est à peu près normal que le
président qui statuerait le mandat le
droit d'y chers amis vous êtes libre
mais parler par vous même et pour vous
même mais pas au monde va pouvoir faire
maintenant donc vous à ce qu'elles vont
à faire en son nom vous approuvez cette
sanction
j'approuve sa liberté de parole sa
liberté de parole à des contreparties
des conséquences et le choix de laurent
wauquiez vous la trouvez pour la
remplacer j'aurais préféré là encore
qu'on débatte et qu'on vote d'accor
j'appartiens à une formation on apprend
par la presse les décisions importantes
c'est parfois surprenants ça demande
beaucoup de sérénité
mais si tous les responsables de deux
des républicains qui s'expriment et qui
vont à contrario des positions de leur
président
si tous ces gens là peuvent être évincés
de la responsabilité ça va faire de
belles charest en l'occurrence la
vice-présidence y en a qu'une et donc
c'est celle et elle dépend du président
quand vous acceptez de la devise
président vous acceptez de travailler
avec un président si vous n'êtes si vous
considérez que ce président a en gros
toujours tort vous en tirez aussi vous
mêmes les conséquences et la semaine
dernière c'est le faiblesse de nos
institutions woerth qui est chargé du
programme au sein du parti des
républicains disait au lendemain du
premier tour
il n'y a pas forcément de leader chez
les républicains c'est une parole aussi
assez forte
il est toujours en fonction et la parole
quand vous avez vous avez bien noté que
les républicains ont adopté un principe
de primaires si on adapte les primaires
c'est qu'on considère que la question
est en effet ouverte
sinon le président qui a pas sinon le
président du parti serait ipso facto le
candidat si on fait des primaires c'est
qu'on considère que le prix le candidat
est ce que c'est pas un problème c'est
un problème un problème c'est presque
comme d'ailleurs vous avez dans la
campagne c'est un sujet qui a été
évoquée à partouze avec des points de
vue différents
mais il est vrai que hollande est
institutionnellement le patron de la
gauche que madame le pen et caritatives
à charismatique mans la lte et
institutionnellement le patron du front
national nicolas sarkozy le président
des républicains
mais puisqu'il ya des primaires cela
veut dire qu'il le président n'est pas
nécessairement le candidat s'il n'y a
pas de primaire écoutez ce que ce que
dit christian estrosi dans paris match
cette semaine là il parle de la ligne et
des idées contrairement à nicolas
sarkozy qu'il dit que restons amis je ne
pense pas que nous devons tenir un
discours toujours plus à droite plus on
va à droite puis on fait monter le front
national plutôt que de chasser sur le
terrain du front national je préfère
chasser le front national du terrain
qu'en pensez vous au site une jolie
formule l idée de base qu'il a tout le
temps non l'élite
l'idée de base c'est qu'en effet les
républicains parce que c'est une
formation majoritaire doit être allées
du centre gauche à la droite
conservatrice
moi j'ai plutôt conservateur mais je
suis heureux d'être avec des gens du
centre
je me sens tout en étant conservateur
profondément différent du front national
parce que ce qui nous sépare
c'est l'acceptation de l'ouverture des
frontières de notre pays notre pays est
un pays européen
c'est un pays qui accepte la
mondialisation et qui doit en tirer les
conséquences c'est à dire d'être à la
hauteur de ce challenge et c'est la
seule façon de réussir
c'est par des fondations vous dites que
les républicains ont eu tendance à tort
de courir derrière le front national ces
derniers mois et réciproquement le front
national
si on défend l'autorité en cours pas
après le front national en cours après
le principe républicain qui est que la
loi commandes et qu'elle doit être
respectée or ya beaucoup de gens qui ne
respectent pas la loi y compris dans la
vie quotidienne depuis les petites
incivilités jusqu'au grand banditisme
voire au terrorisme donc que nous que de
demander à la république de faire
respecter la loi c'est pas excessif
et c'est pas fonds national et la
question donc de la ligne politique vous
dit tiens il va y avoir un candidat aux
primaires donc la ligne politique elle
va être débattue kan mi février lors
d'un conseil national
pendant le débat est constant si vous
voulez le qu'il y est un conseil
national c'est un bon rendez vous je ne
crois pas un seul instant qu'on puisse
épuisé un débat de cette importance
irait alors robin annuellement mais
qu'on puisse les puiser en deux jours de
travail chez les sujets sont quand même
extrêmement compliqué et rené par
exemple prenez par exemple le je ne sais
pas moi la place de la france 2 sur le
terrain énergétique
il ya là comme 21,7 intéressant il ya
des conséquences doit-on les suivent
dans quelles conditions à quel prix nous
avons une politique africaine nous avons
engagé des soldats jusqu'où comme enfin
l'ensemble de ces sujets méritent qu'une
une après-midi de dessin ces sujets ne
sont pas débattues au sein du parti
actuellement en tous les cas ils ne sont
pas suffisamment puisque lorsque nous
avons des
une actualité nous n'avons pas toujours
les points de repère immédiat regardez
le débat sur les réfugiés politiques au
moment de des colonnes de réfugiés
syriens traversant la turquie pour
arriver en europe peut pas dire que la
réponse était parfaitement est unanime
c'est d'ailleurs pas choquant qu'un un
grand parti regarder les grands partis
européens je prends l'exemple de la cdu
ou que je connais bien
vous savez une aile droite et vous avez
un centre gauche à la cdo et c'est
absolument pas le cas on simplement il
faut le savoir
et il faut savoir ce que représente
chacun le problème genre bien sûr je
sais secondes sur le vice-président de
deux des républicains que ce soit l'un
ou l'autre
toute la difficulté c'est qu'ils ont des
convictions mais ils ne sont pas choisis
pour leurs convictions ils seront
choisis pour leur personnalité
problème de nicolas sarkozy en tant que
président des républicains
quand vous prenez la personnalité vous
prenez les plus et vous prenez les moins
il faut accepter le tout mais quand même
on n'est pas vraiment répondu tout à
l'heure à la question sur laurent
wauquiez qui remplace également dit
c'est tout un symbole disons que laurent
wauquiez est une comète très à droite
il est capable de faire une campagne
très haut sorte c'est un garçon plein de
talents de tous alors pas du tout non
mais il est capable d'exprimer avec
force les points sur lesquels ils envie
d'insister un moment déterminé alors la
couverture de l'express que l'on va voir
dit cette semaine que le vrai prennent
le vrai perdant des élections régionales
on le voit c'est nicolas sarkozy est à
l'écouté d'avoir la réaction de son
approche
vous allez réagir après la réaction du
sénateur pierre charon j exprès ces
crises à mon avis je sais pas qui est le
perdant mais c'est peut-être que sa
barbie le perdons c'est pas sarkozy l'a
gagné ça sera déjà marché lui ni un
marché voilà par tous les conflits chez
monsieur rémy qui est parfois un peu
ambigu ça a marché il fallait pas qu'on
le retire faveur de sa liste il
fonctionne mais pas passer les perdons
la table à nicolas sarkozy c'est qu'il
gère bien les républicains les
municipales n'ont pas été perdues tant
s'en faut
les départementales ont été largement
gagné et in fine et l'affichage des
régions est un affichage positif
avec beaucoup de péril interrogations
puisqu'à trois régions qui ont été
gagnés en fin de règne de régions qui
ont été gagnés avec la gauche et une
troisième la mienne qui était gagné alex
ans la gauche
officiellement et peut-être avec un peu
donc le résultat de nicolas sarkozy s'il
était chef d'entreprise il serait
plébiscité par les actionnaires puisque
le patrimoine grandi ce qui est
problématique c'est en effet on le voit
à travers les débats de l'instance c'est
l'avenir à moyen et long terme
parler d'avenir quand vous avez exercé
des responsabilités c'est plus compliqué
que quand vous n'en avez jamais exercé
parler d'avenir pour le front national
c'est facile ils sont jamais rien fait
quelqu'un disait c'est un privilège que
d'avoir il a fait encore ne faut-il pas
en abuser
nous ne pouvons pas abuser de ce
privilège parce que nous sommes au
pouvoir et moi même j'étais militia très
longtemps même aussi être le précédent
voyez donc c'est quand même un embout
table je le reconnais mais je ne suis
candidat à la présidence de la
réplication donc c'est handicapante pour
tous ceux qui ont exercé des
responsabilités de dire demain sera
différent d'hier c'est un handicap et il
le sait et le nous le savons mais il est
revenu sans pouvoir surmonter ce genre
de cas je rappelle que les républicains
enfin l'ump à l'époque on connaît d un
moment particulièrement critique qui
d'ailleurs n'a jamais été véritablement
traité une campagne équivoque un
problème financier majeur sans doute des
comportements d'accaparement de
l'appareil et sa sirène sar est dernière
nous grâce à nicolas sarkozy on n'en
parle plus mais la blessure et réa
d'accord mais si c'est le grand perdant
aujourd'hui est ce que vous pensez pas
le radar a osé peut être gagnant demain
mais c'est pour ça que nous avons
institué des primaires c'est pour que le
candidat gagne une épreuve et apporte
une démonstration de capacité vous
soutenez qui pour la primaire je verrai
les candidats ma préférence elle est
intellectuellement pour françois fillon
parce que ce sont des idées libérales
et qui me contre euro péenne et qui me
conviennent parfaitement
est ce le candidat qui a plus de
facilité c'est aux électeurs il a été
premier ministre et donc c'est vrai
c'est vrai et d'ailleurs dans l'histoire
de ce pays si jacques chirac a été
premier ministre et président de la
république il ya quand même des exemples
gp sait lui aussi à son expérience
derrière lui le premier ministre oui
mais il a une sagesse acquise par la
province et d'ailleurs beaucoup de
français le pensent
moi j'ai ma préférence mais il a en
effet par son son recul de la nouveauté
vous avez parfois le en agriculture on
pratique la jachère et les terres qui
ont pratiqué la jachère sont parait-il
plus riches ensuite pour produire des
moissons et bordelaise alors on va
rester un peu sur la question des
primaires évidemment parce que ça lui
rappelait également le débat a surgi un
petit peu la semaine dernière sur la
date de la primaire voilà lé prévient
été vomi au bureau politique mais un
bureau politique d'une heure et quart
1h20 n'a pas permis d'épuiser le sujet
mais par exemple christian jacob a dit
est-ce qu'on pourrait si on peut le
faire pourquoi ne pas le faire plus tôt
je pense comme lui si on peut le faire
pourquoi ne pas le cancer avant l'été
austral serait l'idéal parce que pendant
les pendant les vacances c'est
simplement impossible donc en septembre
c'est impossible
à partir du moment où le fait pas en
septembre il faut le faire enfin juin
donc ça veut dire une campagne qui
commencerait serons-nous prêt pour une
campagne commencerait en avril certains
disent ça coûtera plus cher organisé dix
mille bureaux de vote ont six mois
oui mais si toute façon je vais vous
dire c'est un rendez vous exceptionnel
que les socialistes ont à peu près
réussi en 2007
pour nous c'est un vrai challenge mais
s'il ya un problème d'opinion l'opinion
peut pas dire à la fois on en a marre de
voir les mêmes têtes et ne pas se
mobiliser le jour on leur donne la
possibilité de changer de tête avec
effectivement le renouvellement qui est
incarnée par d'autres personnes avec la
nouvelle mode en est là oui vous avez
bruno le maire qui est officiellement
candidat nkm envisage lettre à hervé
mariton est candidat avec deux candidats
de conviction plus candidat de succès
mais candidats conviction il ya des
personnalités il y aura donc une
compétition on souhaite moi je souhaite
simplement qu'elle soit la plus massive
possible si c'est une compétition
réduite
elle sera décevante et personne n'y
gagnera donc vous êtes pour je suis pour
l'heure il est pour le principe des
primaires jeudi visait dont le principe
est pour la mise en oeuvre avec un
objectif de 3 millions de lecteurs et
vous ne craignez pas la violence d'une
campagne et une cacophonie non parce que
chacun sait que il y aura un premier
tour il faudra et un deuxième tour et
que toutes les blessures doivent avoir
le temps de cicatriser et plus - les
blessures sont forts plus les cicatrices
sont rapides s'ils voulaient nous savons
dans cette bataille que madame le pen
est au 2e tour presque et donc la
bataille et les contres les 18 à 24 %
que peut rassembler françois hollande
donc il faut faire 25 % pour faire 25 %
il faut qu' aucune blessure à droite et
au centre
on va être compliqué sans blessure a
droit si vous faites là le débat sur les
idées il ya des choses très simples où
vous êtes pour une fiscalité de
l'entreprise et de l'investissement hors
ou qu'on te fous considère itno on peut
maintenir le système actuel ça ça fait
un clivage ne redonne s'insulter pour
dire ça c'est moi tant sur l'économie
qui a des clivages celle ratez rien
ah si quand même vous avez sinon tu sais
s'il n'y avait pas ces clivages nous
aurions régler toute une série de
problèmes entre 2002 et 2012 puisque
nous avons exercé le pouvoir pendant dix
ans pourquoi de les amants nous pas
réglé pas du tout par timidité c'est
parce que il y avait un doute sur
l'opportunité de mettre en avant telle
ou telle mesure si je prends une
or qui est emblématique et et qui divise
profondément la droite d'ailleurs j'en
ai conscience qui lie sf
ça n'a pas été fait avec jacques chirac
et ça a été amorti intelligemment par
nicolas sarkozy mais sympa été remise en
cause
bon prenez la durée du travail ça a été
évoquée sous jacques chirac
ça a été libéralisé et amorti ce nicolas
sakrozy n'a pas été réglé donc c'est ce
type de thèmes on peut très bien les
évoquer sans injurier personnellement
merci démocratie mais qu'elle aime s de
public sénat arrive mais pas avec cette
question gérard longuet faut-il une
recomposition politique que jean pierre
raffarin vous l'avez entendu a été le
premier à l'évoquer c'était lundi matin
il a évoqué des ententes droite gauche
centre face à l'adversaire comme un
front national at at il dit et il est
relayé d'ailleurs depuis notamment par
manuel valls
ce que les français veulent non pas de
gommer les différences politiques
elles sont nécessaires à la vie
démocratique mais c'est que nous
travaillons ensemble c'est que l'intérêt
général soit prédominant que le
sectarisme les petites querelles au sein
des partis ou entre les formations
politiques que les séances à l'assemblée
nationale uzi avec de notre part aussi
ai-je dit le contraire je me donne une
leçon à personne je nous donne une leçon
à chacun d'eux c'est ce que demandent
les français c'est que nous nous
réunissions que nous rassemblions autour
d'une république qui protège la sécurité
et la laïcité et une république qui
donne sa chance à chacun travers la
valeur travail l'engagement la formation
des jeunes et bien sûr la grande île
horrifique il adore l école travaillons
ensemble voilà et le propos est relayée
en termes encore plus vif vous allez
l'entendre par le secrétaire d'état jean
marie le guen
nous avons des institutions qui sont
celles de la vème république
mais nul doute que nos comportements que
nos attitudes que nos postures doivent
changer si on veut être à la hauteur des
attentes des français
au delà il faudra se poser des questions
les uns et des autres pour se savoir
s'il ne convient pas encore d'aller vers
un autre dépassement qui permet de
rassembler la république
voilà un dépassement qui rassemblerait
la république les propos de jean marie
le guen
aujourd'hui mais quelle jeunesse bonsoir
bonsoir à dépassement
vous êtes prêt à ce déplacement les
institutions de la vème sont
parfaitement binaire or l'opinion
française et tertiaire car si enfin en
tous les cas trinitaire si vous me
permettez je l'évoquais tout à l'heure
trois gros tiers extrême droite
souverainiste et antieuropéen d une
gauche divisée mais à dominante
européenne et un centre et une droite
républicaine qui sont au fond très
cohérent parce que ont accepté cet
héritage la construction pn pourquoi je
parle de l'europe parce que c'est
l'image d'une certaine modération que
nous avons en partage
et cette mode et cette modération
partage nous l'avons plus facilement
c'est vrai avec des socialistes qu'avec
le front national mais où est ce que
vous voulez vous dire exactement rien à
rien c'est dans les institutions à rien
dans les institutions de la vème
république parce que le à l'origine
c'est un parlementarisme rationalisé
c'est devenu en 62 un régime
parlementaire et avec le quinquennat
c'est devenu présidentielle pardon et
avec le quinquennat c'est devenu un
régime hyperprésidentiel il n'y a pas un
pays d'europe
je crois pas qu'ils démocratie dans le
monde où le président est autant de
pouvoir obama n'a pas les pouvoirs du
président français donc l'idée d'une
évolution institutionnelle moi ne me
choquerait pas un pouvoir mieux partagée
me choquerait pas je voudrais vous
donner la raison parce que les
présidents de la république croit avoir
une majorité
en réalité les seuls français qui les
soutiennent vraiment ce sont les
français qui ont voté pour eu le premier
tour de la présidentielle au deuxième
tour ce sont des ralliés qui ne veulent
pas de l'autre candidat
ce qui fait que au 1er tour vous faites
entre 25 et 30 2% du café françois euros
c'est ce qu'a fait nicolas sarkozy en
2007 33 % et il a gardé d'ailleurs en
gros c'est prendre 30% sauf que 33 c'est
pas 50 et les rallier dès que ça devient
difficile
ils s'en vont et il voulait se
débrouiller et et donc sa famille est
arrivée nicolas sarkozy
oui c'est arrivé à françois hollande six
mois après son élection il s'est
retrouvé avec les voix qu'il avait pu
rassembler au premier tour donc les
institutions sont faibles le président
est trop fort pour un soutien de
l'opinion qu'ils éprouvent à jour les
institutions non parce que si vous les
institutions c'est quand même un des
trucs qui marchent en france mais on
peut réfléchir en effet sur le rôle du
parlement et sur la composition du
parlement je trouve que le scrutin
majoritaire à deux tours dans le sillage
de la présidentielle c'est l'extinction
du parlement alors nour sénateurs on est
très bien vis-à-vis de ça c'est pour ça
que jean pierre raffarin peut dire des
choses il est élu en dehors du scrutin
présidentiel est dans une logique qui
est beaucoup plus personnel que
partisane je suis dans la même situation
ça me donne beaucoup de liberté
est ce qu'une majorité à l'assemblée
nationale qu'elle dernier mot peut venir
d'un autre système
moi je suis pour le système allemand qui
est un système où vous avez des élus la
moitié du terrain et la moitié de la
proportionnelle ça ne le choquerait pas
je n'ai aucun mandat pour le dire c'est
une conviction personnelle et ce n'est
absolument pas le point de vue des
républicains qui lui point de vue
particulier sur le scrutin majoritaire
je reviens parce que qu'a proposé à jean
pierre raffarin et nous la porte il dit
et pourquoi pas travailler ensemble où
est-ce qu'ils vont revenir jean pierre
raffarin c'est qu'il ya derrière il ya
quelque chose qui voit bien que il ya
des passerelles qui peuvent se faire
entre manuel sur scène un texte
il ya des textes que l'on pourrait voter
plus rapidement et plus profondément
lorsque monsieur macron renouvelle
l'économie on pourrait aller plus vite
sur ces textes et plus loin c'est vrai
que le gouvernement fasse un effort
il faudrait que le gouvernement fasse un
petit effort pour adapter la france aux
réalités son environnement européen et
international déjà vous auriez dit il en
fait vous l'aurez en a pas on n'a pas
empêché le tage de passer comme il ya
mis du temps vous avez eu wheels est
souvent nouveau bond à dos laquelle a
perdu du temps puisque avec nous alors
effectivement si on va dans la réflexion
tout l'est l'autorité de l'état personne
de l'acompte est l'adaptation de
l'économie française a à l'évidence
européenne et mondiale
c'est une évidence pour une majorité des
parlementaires
pas pour la totalité mais pour une large
majorité des parlementaires
on peut progresser sur ces deux voies le
l'autorité de l'erea c'est madame c'est
pas malin de taubira malheureusement
mais ce qu'on peut progresser sur ces
différents points que vous évoquez
gérard longuet jusqu'à envisager je ne
sais pas une alliance des républicains
de droite de gauche face au front
national
non parce que le front national n'est
pas présent parlement est certain de
raquettes au parlement en revanche le
problème du pour le président élu en
2017 se posera en termes simples il
l'emportera devant madame le pen avec
des bois qui viendront de la droite et
de la gauche
il faut donc réfléchir à cette évidence
plus que nous n'avons pas fait en 2002
et nous avons eu tort manuel valls lui
demandant de nouveau président de région
de travailler ensemble
alors là je le rassure ça s'est toujours
passé comme ça j'ai présidé pendant 12 à
nouveau région il ya rien de nouveau
sous le soleil lorsqu'il faut organiser
les transports scolaires choisir des
itinéraires routiers ou défendre un pôle
universitaire en général le clivage
droite gauche ne fonctionne alors
qu'est-ce qui fait manuel valls selon
vous c'est un piège qu'il vous temps
c'est du bon sens tactique ou à sens
d'un bon sens
vous voyez comme or ça alors c'est du
bon sens avec une malice politique le
bon sens parce que beaucoup de pays
européens l'allemagne en particulier on
l'a vu avec madame merkel prolongeant
gerhard schröder il ya des pays qui
savent pratiquer les grandes coalitions
l'analyse tactique c'est d'élargir
l'électorat de françois hollande vers le
centre fait de la drague c'est de la
drague mais et c'est ne peut pas lui en
vouloir il a le droit de faire de la
politique c'est à dire qu'il faut de lui
mener la culture du président de tous
les français pour 2010 est que ça pour
faire le car qui lui permet de
sélectionner pour le deuxième tour et
est-ce que vous avez l'impression que
jean pierre raffarin nathalie kosciusko
morizet et d'autres qui ont ouvert la
porte sont tombés dans le piège
non non on ne sait pas des gens à tomber
dans les pièges jean-pierre a trop
d'expérience politique simplement
quelqu'un qui bloque la les institutions
respire un peu et je ne le compte et je
conteste pas ce besoin
si mais quand vous arrivez en hémicycle
et que vous savez que le débat va être
bloquée petite mais que fait j 6 mois
j'ai entendu tout à l'heure ce qui vous
séparait du front national où la brave
été plusieurs fois ce que je ne
comprends pas c'est qu'est ce qui vous
sépare de la gauche aujourd'hui le fait
que la gauche n'accepte pas les la
modernisation de la france ô
nécessaire pour que nous ne soyons pas
submergés ça c'est le vomir et s'arroger
peut-être peut-être mais pas sûr il ya
un deuxième problème c'est que moi je
crois qu'il faut gagner avant de
répartir et la gauche pense qu'il faut
répartir allant gagner
je pense qu'il faut gagner de l'argent
pour gagner de l'argent avant de le
répartir le donner à ceux qui n'en n'ont
pas et la gauche dit il faut d'abord
répartir l'argent avant de regagner sa
marche pas mais bon ça même de votre
parti vous n'êtes pas tous d'accord sur
cette ligne n'est pas d'accord ovules à
dominante elle est quand même de mon
côté sur sur ce point alors que vous
entendez le premier ministre parlait
d'urgence sur la sécurité d'urgence sur
l'économie vous dit pas quelque part
qu'il aurait pu être des vôtres
je me laisse surtout qu'il est très
embarrassé par sa propre majorité le
drame de françois hollande c'est qu'il
minoritaire dans le pays et à peine
majoritaires dans son camp et je vous
rappelle que monsieur valls candidat à
l'intérieur du parti socialiste avait
fait un score qui était de 2-2 présence
5 5 à 7% alors une vocation dans
l'actualité à propos d'un ministre
s'il ne retire rien à son talent
personnel vous êtes bon sans être aimée
dans votre parti un ministre vous avez
occupé la fonction c'est jean yves le
drian donc vainqueur haut-la-main lieu
en bretagne
il reste donc ministre de la défense est
ce que vous êtes choqués ou n'ont pas
reçu du mult et autorise à la règle
édictée par chef de l'état je trouve que
le chef de l'état a eu complètement tort
d'édicter une règle absolue c'est tout
et maintenant il s'en mord les doigts et
jean yves le drian ils sont dans les
doigts aussi parce qu'il est il est un
petit peu grotesque dire c'est comme ça
et puis son ami le plus proche
lui dit pas du tout en tous les cas
c'est un ministère pour lequel on a
besoin d'union nationale parce que
lorsqu'on engage les troupes à
l'extérieur on ne demande pas la carte
du parti est de ceux qui sont les je
vous parlais dans un instant de la
question militaire vous l'ancien mise à
défaut je voudrais revenir quelques
secondes sur les questions économiques
parce que l'exécutif a annoncé forme
telle au nouvel élan sur le chômage
encore vous allez me dire d'urgence
économique
on n'a pas tout essayé a tendance à dire
françois hollande on n'a pas tout essayé
sur vous évidemment on a le même à rien
essayé ils n'ont rien essayé à eux et
pas seulement te eux et pas seulement
qu'il est
le problème de la france c'est comment
seront compensés à qui j'allais tous
depuis depuis 30 depuis le 1er juillet
absolument absolument moi j'ai participé
les gouvernements qui était d'ailleurs
un peu intérimaire des gouvernements de
corée lee deux cohabitations 86 93
gouvernement intérimaire mais nous
n'avons pas tout essayé
le problème essentiel du chômage chez le
coût du travail parce que il est écrasé
par les charges mais pourquoi il est
écrasé par les charges parce que le
ratio le rapport parle entre les actifs
et les inactifs en france est
déséquilibré nous avons trop d'inactifs
on commence trop tard on arrête trop tôt
on travaille pas assez d'heures par
semaine pas à ces deux semaines dans
l'année et c'est pour ça que le travail
coûte cher parce que les charges de ceux
qui travaillent doivent payer ce que
manuel valls dit il faut mettre le
paquet vous allez mettre le paquet avec
lui dans les régions s'il propose
quelque chose de concret je n'ai aucune
raison de m'y opposer
c'est complètement le domaine des
régions or il a reculé depuis 2000 doute
il a reculé depuis de 2012 sont d'autres
temps partagé l'éducation nationale qui
préfère garder les bons éléments
les entreprises qui font pas toujours
les efforts nécessaires et
l'administration qui rend très compliqué
l'emploi d'un apprenti donc nous avons
d'avoir tout le monde en parle
mes torts partagés seigneur fréquents
dans les réformes françaises sur la
formation professionnelle c'est
l'impression que c'est l'alpha et
l'oméga
c'est votre votre idée aussi servir à
2,10 et les chiffres c'est l'information
professionnelle c'est indispensable
ce qui compte le plus c'est la
motivation professionnelle
nous avons des français qui ont des
poils dans la main il faut le savoir
c'est à dire qui c'est trop dur c'est
trop loin c'est pas ce que je veux pour
regarder moi j'ai été formé pour faire
du théâtre et on me propose de faire du
commercial mais non ils réalisent et
peut-être un tout petit peu pas tant que
ça la toile dans la masse et une formule
qui risque de rester alors c'est une
vérité tous les employeurs qui vous
disent il ya des jeunes qui viennent
pointer chez moi et qui me disent
surtout ne proposait rien j'attends
plusieurs mois avant de le medef
aujourd'hui
ce modèle à quai sur ce sujet le medef
demande une exonération des totale des
charges sociales
lorsqu on embauche un salarié au moins
sur les deux premières années et surtout
une augmentation de deux points de la
tva
vous êtes d'accord avec ça alors le le
medef est cohérent j'aurais préféré
d'ailleurs qu'il ajoute à l'augmentation
de la tva qui est possible en france
puisque nous avons pas le taux le plus
élevé d'europe tant s'en faut qu'ils
nous disent qu'elles sont les charges
qu'il entend les dépenses qui n'entrent
en supprimer parce que moi je suis pour
l'allègement des charges
à condition quand façon d l'honnêteté de
dire voilà ce qu'on ne paiera plus et
j'attends du medef qui nous disent voilà
ce que je ne suis prêt à ne plus payer
généré les baisses le medef fait son
métier c'est pas drôle d'être chef
d'entreprise ans a normalement dans un
environnement difficile donc le men et
essayent d'obtenir des gouvernements ce
qui peuvent aider les entreprises
il fait son job à produire des chômeurs
s'est prononcé hier soir le mot
contrepartie sans plus de précisions il
ya sur sur france 2 vous exigez vous des
contreparties à l'indemnisation du
chômage que notamment pour ceux qui
auraient rebelles dans la main pour
reprendre votre formule gérard longuet
la production on parle des régions si
une phase si on faisait suivre la
formation professionnelle plus
sérieusement par les régions et le
travail de l'emploi de pôle emploi par
les régions on aurait une meilleure
connaissance des cas individuels parce
que il ya une force dans la
décentralisation qui est la proximité et
cette proximité vous permettre de juger
la réalité des choses beaucoup mieux que
de paris j'en viens sur les questions de
défense vous l'ancien ministre la france
a tiré aujourd'hui les premiers missiles
de croisière air-sol peut-être un peu
technique mais ça veut dire que ce sont
des missiles qu'on peut envoyer du lourd
pour faire simple c'est une première la
force en libye
enfin libye mais là aussi c'est une
première est ce que ça veut dire que
c'est un changement de stratégie
vous voyez ça comme une intensification
non non non je crois que c'est une
cohérence le gouvernement nous dit moi
je veux détruire
émirat islamique à part le par la frappe
aérienne je pense que c'est un choix qui
s'éteint le résultat est improbable
on peut contenir ont peu compliqué on
peut affaiblir on ne peut pas le
détruire par la force aérienne
en revanche le missile de croisière
c'est d'abord premièrement vous
permettez moi de vous dire avec un petit
peu de brutalité c'est une façon de
tester tout ce que l'on sait faire et de
le tester pour avoir des cibles
militaires avec le moins de dommages
collatéraux celle avantages du missile
de croisière c'est que sa précision fait
que ça tombe sur michel grossiord et
partir vous c'est une chose qu'on
annonce effectivement une grande
précision
voilà donc mais ça ne réglera rien sur
le fond ça contiendra l'émirat islamique
la crainte du seigneur et le
commencement de la sagesse mais s'il n'y
a pas de solution de politique on arrive
à passer le bilan des frappes là jusqu'à
présent on considérait garda bleus je ne
suis pas capable de porter un jugement
péremptoire et définitif ce qu'il faut
c'est comparer ce qui se serait passé
s'il y avait pas eu de frappe et si on
relève de tomber la question politique
selon vous quelle est la solution
aujourd'hui pour obtenir des résultats
plus rapides sur le plan militaire et
une exigence qui était rappelé hier à
qu'obama le problème il est profondément
politique il faut que les syriens se
disent il ya une force qui se dégage
cette force ce n'est pas l'émirat
islamique
ce n'est peut-être certainement pas
bachar el-assad
mais c'est certainement damas est ce que
représente damas sur les la défense
française on a même dit à un moment
qu'on avait plus munitions qui avait
obligé d acheter aux états unis je peux
arriver
ouais c'est pas de sa convenance l'état
de notre défense non ça veut dire que
nous avons à nous mettre au rythme d'une
opération et se mettre au rythme d'une
opération sa demande des commandes il
anormal de ne pas sur commande et sabots
de préfèrent de ne pas commander des
missiles qui sont qu'on peut pas garder
éternellement qui ont une en quelque
sorte une forme de péremption
donc il est assez logique de s'adapter
aux besoins sur la question des
alliances des coalitions vous avez
peut-être vu que la turquie envisage une
nouvelle coalition
peut-être même en dehors de ce qui se
passe aujourd'hui avec la france et même
les états unis la turquie joue un rôle
étrange
elle joue un rôle c'est une première
manche n'arrivera deuxièmement sont des
sunnites et troisièmement sont des gens
directement concernés par le problème
kurde et donc jusqu'à présent ils ont
joué un rôle tout à fait envie qu en
permettant les murs à l'émirat islamique
de prospérer notamment les crises
exportations de pétrole
si la turquie veut être plus impliqués à
condition que les choses soient claires
tant mieux 34 pays musulman aujourd'hui
se sont réunis sous l'égide de l'arabie
saoudite ça vous inquiète ou est-ce que
vous estimez qu'on peut leur faire
confiance
je pense que la question en effet et est
lié à l'entente des sunnites séoudiens
et des sunnites turc
les 1 100 arabe et garde les lieux
saints
les hommes sont turcs n'ont pas les
mêmes responsabilités mais ils sont
puissants et c'est l'entente des deux
peut donner un élément fort
est-ce qu'il faut qu'on se poser la
question de l'entrée de la turquie dans
l'union européenne
j ai toujours été opposé et chaque jour
j oui absolument j'ai beaucoup de
sympathie pour la turquie de mustafa
kemal pour le souvenir ottoman c'est un
grand pays
on n'a pas besoin d'être européen pour
être heureux mais vous avez vu que hier
l'union européenne a ouvert un nouveau
chapitre des négociations et parce que
l'union aujourd'hui j'avais à se
réformer et économiquement vous avez un
clan dans l'union européenne qui
souhaite élargir pour ne pas avoir à
approfondir moi je pense exactement le
contraire je pense qu'il faut
approfondir plus d'autres des larges
est-ce qu'il va falloir bientôt
intervenir en libye cette fois où le
groupe etat islamique progresse vous
l'avez vu avec le plus de 200 km de
côtes son contrôle
encore là c'est vraiment une affaire
politique on a deux pouvoirs qui
devraient réfléchir au fait que s'ils ne
s'entendent pas c'est une troisième
force qui l'emportera de la guerre ce
qui se passe en france sur l'état
d'urgence il ya un bilan qui est fait
ces derniers jours par manuel valls
vous vous tirez quel bilan de cet état
d'urgence qu'on a donné à la police les
moyens d'intervenir et qu'on a la police
à gagner du temps en terme de sécurité
est ce qu'il n'ya pas des dérives haut
de crainte
elles ont été formulées à juste titre
mais nous sommes en état de guerre on
peut pas parler des tables hier ait
considéré que que la vie est comme d'hab
n'en avait pas d'inquiétude pour les
libertés publiques en termes clairs
gérard longuet
g il faut que les états d'urgence
s'arrête un moment ou à noter thériault
gens ce n'est pas un état normal
mais tant que nous n'avons pas retrouvé
la perspective d'une sérénité absolue
l'état d'urgence même championne
attendra aussi l'avis du conseil des
paquets très important oui mais alors je
vais vous dire je préfère confier la
sécurité des français un gouvernement
responsable et un ministre de
l'intérieur qui fait son job cas des
juristes pour lequel j'ai le plus grand
respect sont les meilleurs camarades de
promotion qui sont au conseil d'état
mais la sécurité c'est aussi un problème
du quotidien peu importe l'avis du
conseil d'état n'ont naturellement mais
c'est exact mais d'abord je n'ai pas le
souvenir que le conseil d'état se soit
exprimée au moment de la bataille de
verdun il même au moment de la bataille
de la marne d'amour peut-être si on
attend juste une question sur la
déchéance de nationalité qui est aussi
dans cet état d'urgence qui pourrait
être dans la constitution les voiles
commencent à s'élever un petit peu à
gauche parce que c'est vrai que sa
décision la prise pendant l'état
d'urgence à gauche et des ministres qui
en ce moment-même disent des choses
nationalité c'est symbolique ça ne
réglera rien ça ne règle rien et ça fait
plaisir à ceux qui ont la cherté la
nationalité française et qui ont une
autre idée de la france le terrorisme je
peux vous dire que la déchéance de
nationalité
c'est un immense bonheur pour tous les
français d'origine de la diversité
qu'ils disent moi ma nationalité je la
mérite on me la retire pas donc vous
déformez cette mesure au nom de sa
liberté symbolique charles s'ajouter 5
millions pour celui lagarde et qui sont
fiers d'eux
garder oui il ya une autre mesure qui
est défendu par exemple par laurent
wauquiez dont on avocat e et on en a
parlé pendant cette émission il lui il
demande qu'on ne s'embarrasse pas des
arguties juridiques pour placer par
exemple en centre des détentions des
individus qui ont été identifiés comme
dangereux est ce que ça vous paraît être
une bonne solution est exactement ce que
la république a fait sous la ivème et
sous la 5ème avec l'internement
administratif avec saint maurice ardoise
pour les activistes aux as où algérie
française s'il y avait d'autres centres
de détention pour les activistes pro fln
et ça a permis d'éviter à des gens de
faire des bêtises
donc c'est une mesure que vous soutenez
également sait pas qu'elle n'est pas
chaud mais pas été tout à fait clairs
tout à l'heure sur jean yves le drian
vous êtes heureux qu'il reste ministre
de la défense carme chacon savoureux qui
dresse ministre à tout prendre je
préfère jean yves le drian est ce que
vous allez regarder votre téléphone
parce que peut-être la recomposition non
moi je suis heureux d'être sénateur et
d'avoir la liberté de parole que donne
au skate voix l'a démontré ce soir
d'élection merci à vous gérard longuet
merci mais qu'elle aimait ce bon soir à
tous et à très vite